so today's question comes from jamie in
pennsylvania
she visits daveramsey.com to ask my
boyfriend and i
are looking into getting married in the
next year or so he has two children
ages four and seven from a previous
marriage and split custody with no child
support or alimony
we both have debt and healthy savings
what are the benefits of getting married
would you suggest a prenup so that i
protect myself prior to getting married
we would like to have a child of our own
god willing i love his children but feel
that i should not be financially
responsible for them
whoo jamie there's a lot here um this
a lot of this might be better in a in a
more long-form call i'd love to ask some
follow-up questions here
dave what do you think oh hi this is
your that's your friend
i'll jump in believe me i have an
opinion but you go ahead i do too i i
don't think y'all are ready to get
married i think you're having some
um this idea that i love his children
but i'm not going to be financially
responsible for them
when you join somebody in marriage and
they already have kids
you are joining a family and you are
joining those kids and i know that those
two kids have a mom
but they are also getting you right so
you're going to be a step parent you're
going to be involved
in the raising of these young kids
you're going to be
involved in the paying for them to get
clothes
and food that's what marriage is is the
joining of incomes the joining of homes
the joining of values the joining of of
home raising so
um no you're fine i'm gonna say i might
suggest that he get a prenup
um to protect his kids um but again
those that takes deeper questions
um about finances and money where people
are at but
the benefits of getting married is you
get to do life
with a partner you get to do life
anchored in i know that come what may
they're gonna be there
um and so there's some there's just some
red flags in this question
that make me think you're not there yet
the old book of common prayer says
in sickness and in health for richer for
poor unto thee
all my worldly goods i pledge
unless you have extreme wealth and you
don't
no prenup if you love your little life
and your little money and your little
independence
more than you love him don't get married
if you're not willing to take his kids
on as if they're yours
don't get married you're not ready for
marriage
you're not ready because you still value
your stuff
more than the relationship and until
you're ready to put the relationship
with him the kids his mother his father
his crazy uncle and his broke down car
all on your shoulders and carry them
then you're not ready for marriage right
and especially
if you feel like you're going to come
into this house and the kids aren't
going to have access to your money
just that language and of itself you're
not ready to get married
yeah exactly you got to be all in
all in all in and by the way it's not
test driving the car to shack up
because you're not all in and it's not
going to fix these exact issues
and so you date and you maintain a
separate household
and you have quality relationships and
you grow in the relationship to the
point that
being with him and being married is more
important than any
other single goal you have and they all
become subordinate to that man or woman
you if you do not make your other goals
subordinate too
meaning that we're going to agree on
doing these things together and the only
possible way that the man you love more
than life itself is going to have a good
life if his kids do
and so you you're you're taking them on
i i think this is worth pointing out
i i love where you're headed with this
his responsibility
will be to those two kids and for
somebody to try to wedge their way
between now you come back help that's
exactly right
not become an additional problem right
or an additional burden or an additional
responsibility
because these kids are already going
through enough they are already going to
go through
guilt they're going to go through
loyalty issues they're going to go
through what did i
do to make mom and dad split up this
vacuum of
joy and attention in that house they're
going to take that on that's what four
and seven year olds do
and for somebody else to show up and say
hey i love you guys
this is not so much not so much come on
man
i love you but not so much you're not
there yet you're not there
you can be you can be but you need a
heart change i make forty six thousand
dollars a year and i need a prenup
no you don't no you don't you don't have
anything to pre-nup
when do you recommend a prenup dave
where there's extreme wealth
on one side and not on the other okay so
let's say that
um you're marrying someone that has 10
million dollars and you have
40 000 okay i would put a prenup in
place
because not necessarily because of the
couple i do
i do really in-depth detailed
pre-marriage counseling
because you're gonna face some unusual
challenges give me some different
tensions in there exactly
number one but the reason for the prenup
is
it's not the couple that i've run into
as a financial coach that's been the
problem
it's the extended family right and
that's i i like them only for
wealth and kids right to protect the
extended family is
uh no i mean it's like his mother's a
nut case
and you cannot keep her out of the
discussion unless there's a prenup right
and so what it does it just backs
everybody off and your crazy cousin
thinks you just got rich because you
married the guy with 10 million dollars
that's right
and that kind of stuff so crazy eddie
shows up with his dadgum rv out front
you know cousin eddie right cousin eddie
that's right and uh so
and that that's you know and hey you
murdered 10 millionaires i'm here i'll
get my part you know that's right and so
uh you know that's the stuff that
happens but when you got a prenup you go
i don't know
it just it's it backs off the crazy and
it's really helpful with that
and it's very very important that you
take the time but we're just
uh folks have fairly even typical
finances
you don't need a prenup